Cows can be best friends and experience stress
when they are removed from each other.
In 1386 a pig in France was executed by public
hanging for the murder of a child.
When Beethoven went deaf, he composed his
music by hacking the legs off his piano and
sitting on the floor so he could feel the
vibrations.
French was the official language of England
for over 600 years.
Honey is the only food that never spoils.
In New York city approximately 1,600 people
are bitten by other humans each year.
The colder the room is that you sleep in,
the more likely you are to have a bad dream.
Two-thirds of Africa is in the northern hemisphere.
Theoretically the Pope can resign but, since
he is the Supreme Pontiff, there is no one
qualified to accept his resignation.
Beaver's teeth never stop growing.
The average speed of the wind has fallen by
60% in the last 30 years.
The average adult human has 1 to 4 kilogram's
of bacteria in his or her body.
You can see your nose at all times, your brain
just chooses to ignore it because it's not
important.
Bill Gates hacked into and tweaked his school's
computer programme's coding so that he was
placed in a class with mostly female students.
The last two speakers of the Mexican language
Zoque are both in their seventies and refuse
to speak to one another.
Almost any domestic cat can run faster than
Usain Bolt.